okay so in this video we're going to
discuss the cell membrane or the plasma
membrane the outer boundary of our cells
so let's get started
same probably heard that the cell
membrane or the plasma membrane the job
is to control the passage of materials
into and out of a cell and that's kind
of where that's what we're going to be
discussing today
what is controlled and also what is the
cell membrane itself made from well at
its most basic the cell membrane is a
double layer of what are called
phospholipids so here we have a zoomed
in zoomed in image of a phospholipid and
we're going to dissect this and and
analyze a phospholipid in more detail
but notice how there's are two rows of
phospholipids and almost looks like one
is standing right side up and almost
looks like one is standing upside down
we'll explain why that is in a little
bit so an important feature of the
plasma membrane is that it is
semipermeable or selectively permeable
this means that only some materials may
pass through the plasma membrane not
everything notice how the black circles
are freely able to pass but the larger
orange hexagons are not so molecules
that are easily able to pass tend to be
small molecules and they tend not to
have a charge to them carbon dioxide and
oxygen are two great examples of this
molecules that are unable to pass or
have difficulty passing tend to be large
molecules or molecules that have a
charge or ions ions or atoms that have a
charge you know glucose is a large
molecule unable to pass freely through
the plasma membrane sodium and chlorine
are ions atoms with with a charge to
them and because of their charge they're
not able to freely pass through the
phospholipid bilayer
well I actually want to look into a
phospholipid in more detail so here's
our phospholipid from earlier notice how
it has a lump of atoms at the top a
cluster of atoms you know we call this
the head and then dangling down there
appear to be two chains of of atoms and
when these are the tails now when we
look at the head of a fossil that but
it's actually chemically its polar and I
want you to know that it's made from two
parts there is the phosphate group and
notice how there's phosphorus at the
bottom of of that of that structural
diagram there and then the second part
of the polar head is the glycerol part
and there's the glycerol part now if you
recall polar molecules are molecules
where an area is slightly positive and
another area is slightly negative well
it turns out by the nitrogen turns out
this is where the phosphate group tends
to have a positive charge to it and down
by the oxygens tend to have a negative
charge so this is the reason why the
head is polar and as a result the head
is said to be hydrophilic now when we
break apart the word into prefix and
suffix you know hydro implies water and
silicon means loving so the head is
water loving it will seek out water and
that's going to be important once we get
into the cell membrane and all the other
parts in a moment and then there are the
tails that we said earlier so the tails
tend to be two chains of fatty acids
that have attached to the blue glycerol
and notice how one of the fatty acids
has a kink in it well that's because
it's a unsaturated fatty acid and the
one that's perfectly straight is a
saturated fatty acid and so the two
tails there are what are called
hydrophobic they don't have a charge hi
Joe still implies water phobic implies
its theory now it doesn't actually fear
and run away from water it's just not
attracted to water so when we look at
lipids in the cell membrane in a few
moments you're going to see how the
hydrophilic head and the hydrophobic
tails orient themselves you know for
simplicity you're often going to see
phospholipids just drawn as a circle
with two lines dangling down and from
from now on for the rest of this video
this is how I'm going to illustrate a
phospholipid as well so when we look at
the arrangement we mentioned earlier
that the cell membrane is a phospholipid
bilayer there are two layers of
phospholipids that make up our cell
membrane and the head the polar heads
tend to be on the outside and the
nonpolar tails tend to be sandwiched on
the inside well why is this this is
because cells are surrounded by water on
both sides outside the cell the cells
are in a watery solution inside the cell
the cell contains cytoplasm which is
mostly made from water so you know water
is polar and the heads of the
phospholipids are polar so they're
attracted to one another that's why the
the phospholipids orient themselves with
the heads facing the watery environment
and so we have the hydrophilic heads on
the outside and the hydrophobic tails on
the inside because of their attraction
to water so now I'd like to discuss all
the components of the plasma membrane
not just the phospholipid bilayer the
plasma membrane is also referred is
often referred to as a fluid mosaic
model now when I hear the word mosaic I
tend to think of artwork you know
various artworks are called mosaics
because they're made from a wide variety
of elements you know here we have ten
pieces of art made from tiles different
size color shapes and they've been
arranged to make these two beautiful
pieces of art and so the plasma membrane
is very much a mosaic because it's made
from a wide variety of components and
it's also called a fluid model and I'll
explain why that is in a little bit
later first of all let's start looking
at the components the phospholipids we
already mentioned with their hydrophilic
heads
and they're hydrophobic tails will tend
to allow small non-polar or non Dalek
eul's to pass carbon dioxide oxygen are
two gases that can freely pass through
the phospholipid bilayer we also see
these yellow geometric shaped structures
embedded within the tails of the
phospholipids these are cholesterol
molecules now when we hear cholesterol
we tend to think of you know someone
with too high of cholesterol and some
negative health effects but cholesterol
plays a very important role it helps you
prevent the phospholipids from
separating too far from one another
therefore it keeps the cell membrane
compact and and bound together and thus
given the cell membrane its flexibility
so cholesterol plays a really important
role in the overall health and function
of the plasma membrane in the green
chain of circles these are carbohydrates
now sometimes these carbohydrates are
attached to proteins and sometimes
they're attached to lipids but these
carbohydrates are sticking out of the
cell and they are used for
identification or recognition purposes
this is one way our immune system knows
to target foreign cells but to ignore
cells that belong to us and for instance
our blood type is determined by the
carbohydrates they're on ourselves
another part I want to mention is this
blue channel in the middle the protein
channel now like the name implies it's
made from protein and it allows certain
objects to pass objects that can't just
pass through the phospholipid bilayer
like oxygen and like carbon dioxide but
larger molecules or even molecules that
have a charge to them
glucose is a great example glucose is
unable to pass through the phospholipid
bilayer but cells need glucose so
glucose is actually taken in through
these protein channels to the interior
of the cell another part I want to
mention is the cytoskeleton notice how
there are these threads that crisscross
and zigzag on the inside of the cell
well these are the protein threads that
make up the cytoskeleton now there's
different kinds of protein threads there
are the microtubules and microfilaments
and their intermediate filaments and the
this the proteins of the cytoskeleton
helped to give internal support you know
the analogy is like it's like the
framing on a house to help to support
the house so it doesn't topple over but
they also play another role the
cytoskeleton is also a pathway for
molecules to transport and travel on
here we see some molecules trans being
transported throughout the cell and even
some of the molecules being exiting in
and exiting from the cell but you can
see they are travelling along the
protein threads of the cytoskeleton so
this is the reason why again the plasma
membrane is called the fluid mosaic
model
well mosaic because it's made from a
variety of parts but fluid because those
parts can drift around and are in motion
the parts are not static the
phospholipids are able to drift left and
right the carbohydrates the proteins the
cholesterol molecules and so the
fluidity can be affected by temperature
and other environmental factors but
holding a lot of the phospholipids
together again are those cholesterol
molecules that are embedded within
the tails of the phospholipids so there
you have it there's our practice quiz
here if you're in my biology class you
know pause the video try to answer these
questions on a separate sheet of paper
and I'd love to check your answers
before school or after school one day
I'd also like to hear your comments in
the box below so I hope you enjoyed
thanks for watching